we have to talk about books i like books
i like reading and i say more books the
better as a general rule doesn't mean
every book is appropriate for every
setting or every situation okay we've
talked about that before but the real
question i have is according to these
right wingers
is banning books good or bad and you
might be saying well david no it's
obviously good or it's obviously bad but
it's really not so clear
because we see both perspectives from
this modern american book burning
contingent that exists
in the right
as i talked to you about not that long
ago
book ban efforts have hit their highest
levels in at least 20 years and it's the
right not the left that's doing this we
looked at this article uh must have been
when is this article even from about a
month ago we look we did the story a
couple weeks ago three three weeks ago
or so that book ban efforts led by the
american right wing are at their highest
level in 20 years now what we mean by
book bans differs in different
situations in some cases what we're
talking about is a movement by the right
to ban a book from being used in school
sometimes it's novels sometimes it's
certain history books etc they're not
necessarily calling for the books to not
be published or for the books to be
against the law but they certainly want
to cancel a teacher's ability to say
here's a book that i want to teach from
they don't want to give teachers that
opportunity
in other cases it's confusion about what
it even means and we're going to get to
that in a moment but
we know that the efforts to ban books
are at multi-decade highs led by the
american right wing
so they must be in favor of the book
bans right
well apparently not because remember the
dr seuss situation this was now about a
year ago well it's actually hard to
believe it's been a year but it has been
a year
where
the publisher of dr seuss books said hey
you know what
some of these books this is our review
we're a private business we can make the
decisions that are right for us
we believe that some
of these dr seuss books they have
elements that are not really sensitive
to modern cultural sensitivities we're a
private business we're a publisher and
we think it's not good for business to
keep publishing some of these so we're
not going to keep printing more copies
we're not burning the books we're not
saying the books should be against the
law we're not saying people can't read
them we just think continuing to print
these particular books is no longer in
line with what's best for us and the
right went crazy saying oh my god the
left is banning the books they're
canceling dr seuss it's terrible always
allow the books everywhere everywhere
everywhere oh okay so they're against i
guess limitations on books except now
as we talked about yesterday and as
we've been talking about for several
months
they seem fine banning books
when it's books that they don't like
when it's history books that tell
the real story as far as we know at this
time
of uh slavery
of racial discrimination of all sorts of
different aspects of history all of a
sudden the very same right-wingers who
were saying they're canceling dr seuss
they say we got to get these books the
hell out of here
we now are learning about this new
effort in florida
to
reject math textbooks because they
contain so-called critical race theory
although
ron desantis and other floridians have
not been able to provide a single
substantive example of where such
critical race theory exists so i guess
the question of is banning books good or
bad
the answer is well i guess it depends on
their mood
i guess it depends on which books
i guess it depends on who's doing it and
why and it's a very similar phenomenon
with protests if you're protesting
police brutality if you're protesting in
favor of uh black lives matter if you're
protesting in defense of george floyd
well then these protests are dangerous
to law enforcement and we've got to back
the blue and they're
all violent and looting and all these
different things but
if you're protesting against
joe biden being the president and
getting sworn in because he was elected
on january 6 well then you're doing the
right thing and you're being treated
very unfairly by everybody and what
about back the blue because they beat up
some cops oh no no we don't care about
that all of a sudden because they were
protesting against the certification of
the election oh so i guess it's not
really so simple and the principle here
is the one i've been telling you about
now for years
which is
they don't even really care about their
own stated principles they stake out
apparent principles
to justify
the end results that they already want
if their principles all of a sudden
would point to actually black lives
matter can protest
actually
you shouldn't ban these books
then they change their principles
because their principles are no longer
convenient to their pre-existing end
goals and this is the theme we've been
following for years at this point in
time
i don't think this is going to stop
anytime soon and in particular because
they don't really want to engage on what
should climate policy be
what should policy be on renewable
sources of energy what should the top
tax rate be they can only engage
completely superficially taxes are bad
green new deal is bad
because they are unwilling or unable to
engage substantively on those issues
they're going to keep pushing this stuff
and it works i don't want to be a broken
record but part of why glenn younkin won
the virginia gubernatorial race
is because this stuff works i will ban
teaching of critical race theory who's
teaching it well it doesn't matter i
will ban it wow i'm going to vote for
this guy
this stuff works let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
deepakman